I think if we tried to write down a
universe on on the piece of paper that
was the most simple in the most elegant
there's a lot of things you wouldn't
find so it uh it's all all the way all
the details intermesh are very important
to for example allowing people to exist
and I mean on the biological level I
guess this is obvious that we're very
dependent on respiratory system and all
the rest of it which is not something
that you would just invent again if you
had a random piece of paper and
certainly what we've discovered this
sort of pie picture of the universe that
you have four percent atoms the dark
matter which i think is a that is a
soluble problem I think we're on the
edge of solving that one but then all of
a sudden this dark energy appeared out
as a complete mystery this was in the
late 1990s so i think i was saying
around then in the past ten years around
the turn of the millennium it's really
been the golden age for cosmology from
the point of view of data coming in and
really affecting our thinking so this is
a very bizarre probably illogical thing
from our current understanding of what
powers the dark energy so what the the
thing that we see is that the apparently
the universe is not only expanding that
we've known that for a long time but
also accelerating and the way this was
originally found was by looking at very
bright supernovae these are the
explosions of dying stars and these
distant supernovae were seen to be
fainter than anybody expected and one
interpretation was that they're
accelerating away from us and at first
it wasn't clear what really was going on
but that is the consensus picture at
this point that this you have this
acceleration driven by this powerful new
well it's this is this isn't it's almost
like an antigravity so whereas dark
matter makes up galaxies it has a normal
gravitational interaction this other
stuff has some kind of negative pressure
it pushes things apart and it could
either be a new kind of energy density
of vacuum energy density or it could be
telling us that our basic equations are
wrong and we
have to rethink everything so this one
has people very excited and puzzled and
it's not going to be answered you know
that's this one will not be answered
tomorrow but it's a it's a big one and
it certainly affects the future
evolution of the universe as well